it's another
holiday that i don't even celebrate
[Music]
and here we go
ladies and gentlemen welcome back to
your favorite
podcast you know the name
[Music]
listen i gotta be quiet today i know
this sounds ridiculous
but i'm not even going to keep going
with the theme song because let me just
let me just get right into something
right here so rachel and her friend are
downstairs
and they recording a podcast right
they're trying to do a fashion podcast
okay
so i had to like no one even helps me
for my podcast
and i'm down here [ __ ] setting up
lights
getting the mics making sure the whole
thing is set up for them
you know and then they're all like don't
be too loud it's like it's
it's a nightmare and then there and then
like i'm trying to explain to them how
to work the the thing right how to turn
on the uh
turn on the the mixer recorder you know
the h6 zoom
you know they're not even paying
attention because they're looking at the
the test the test you know on their
phone
of the you know what it looks like and
they're just like oh i don't know if i
should wear that outfit and the other
one's like well i know
and then they're just going on and on
about nonsense that has nothing to do
with
what's happening for to do this let me
put my air quotes up podcast but
whatever i'm supportive i'm a support
you know what i mean i'm just trying to
be supportive
it doesn't matter if it if if it does
well or not like
i hope it does great you know what i
mean better than mine
but if it doesn't it doesn't what does
it even matter because it doesn't even
matter even with mine right but
it's just a nightmare okay so i had to
cut the the intro short today
but welcome to griffin with griffin and
so i finally got somebody uh to help me
out he's doing a little video editing
and stuff for me
uh nicknamed wiggy you know there's i'll
show you i'll show you guys a picture of
him right there
so there he is right there the cute
white boy you know always got his shirt
off on his instagram it's too much but
he's talented
[Laughter]
talented so he made this video and i'll
show you guys later
just uh because i just said some and i
want to use it for a patreon content so
i'm gonna show it to you here
on the podcast you know i just like i
went to the dentist with rachel
and uh i recorded myself we were just we
just did like some
some recordings so we you know we
iphoned him with griffin and then i
sent him the videos and he put it
together like what he did and it's just
hilarious you know actually we should
just play it right now right so
here's what the guy put together so if
you're listening
you're not gonna be able to see it so
you're gonna have to go
you're gonna have to go to youtube and
check it out
because it's not gonna be on the audio
side you know i'm not gonna play for the
audio but anyways
so let's just assume i played it let me
do one of my red glassman snaps
and here it is okay drank too much
coffee and
we were headed to the dentist so
i had to go to the bathroom so i had to
tell rachel turn this car around
and take me home because who wants to
poop in some strange dentist office
but she didn't get it and got all mad at
me
so now we're breaking up because i had
to go poop
okay so
nobody ever did something
like eric pooled in this car just now
so anyway
all right so we're headed to the dentist
and this is the hot dentist that rachel
said this is the only woman i would be
able to cheat on her with so i can't
wait to meet her
okay so i didn't give you full
permission and i was just
like you know i actually have told the
dentist this like last week about you
so she's excited to meet you too but
luckily she's married
she has kids i mean small hurdle
but at the same time i've never seen her
without her mask
oh she could be ugly um but she has a
dentist oh
mask that's right you just remind me i
gotta get my mask to go to the dentist
which is stupid because my mouth is
gonna be open at the dentist so it's
like it don't even make any sense
i don't have a i don't know where my
mouth starts in the car can you come on
oh yeah she has mass in the car okay
well see you run away
so we're on the way to dentist this is
gonna be my new patreon content
[Music]
iphone in with griffin that's what i'm
gonna call it so
if you want iphone and griffin you need
to sign up for the patreon
i'm actually going to make content
there's rachel so
you know it is what it is
but we're off to the up dentist
the dentist on a saturday even though my
teeth are nice
but my teeth are nice no they're not you
got cavity issues
all right guys throwing the trash out
but that's what i do
all right all right so now we're in the
car headed to the dentist
rachel's engagement car her promise car
well if it's an engagement car would it
be hour
or no actually a ring is just mine
this is what i have to deal with this is
this is the nightmare that is my life
it's kind of weird how
like you would think you would share a
ring because
what do i get to wear it on tuesdays
when is it my ring
well i guess we it wouldn't fit both of
us at the same time it would be like
your pinky ring for my index finger
i don't even know i think my pink i
think
yeah i don't even think it'll fit my
thinking because she's so skinny
you're so scared me all right so we're
off to the dentist
and i'll let you know how hot the
dentist is
can't wait to see okay so now we're
arguing about what i have on
i have on my superman shirt okay and
then i have on
these this matches this
matches from afar it matches but from a
close it doesn't
she just
you know what i mean we're literally
supposed to be there in five minutes
you said it was five minutes away
well that gives us no walking time from
the
parking lot to the office i think we're
gonna be fine all right
i think so too but
[Music]
you might have to turn around again we
are not turning
around again he will poop in the office
i'm gonna poop in your car is what i'm
gonna do
just right in your car well it's your
hour engagement car
okay so we're here in the parking lot of
the dentist and it doesn't look like
anyone is here
there's a car destination
it's just the other parking lot that we
normally park in it's closed
and it's a saturday but she i talked to
her on the phone
i think she made a special appointment
just to meet you
all right well let's go saturday
dentistry
[Music]
rachel gave me this clan mask oh my god
it's better to not have synthetic dyes
on your face
oh now it's okay now synthetic dyes okay
here we go everybody
you always find some sort of thing
to make it about that so
i'm gonna meet my new dentist with my
clan mask on
where are we going okay here we go
going to the dentist and we're gonna be
happy
how do you change it around i feel like
such an old man
all right so here we go oh there's a
wi-fi area
is this it she doesn't even know how to
get in
oh we're in all right guys let you know
what's up
but the front of the building is
actually really nice
so apparently we're going to some back
alley dentistry
this is like a good el salvador or
something
ooh it is nice
okay you're out let me see that smile
how's my smile yeah it's good what did
you do um they just
grounded down the crown a little bit
because
um i was getting cold irritation oh
hi hello now it's your turn you don't
mind if i film
listen to me i'm sorry i interrupted you
guys no it's totally okay this is this
is the new dentist
[Laughter]
oh well it's going good
got my teeth cleaned yeah
i might take these glasses with me
there's my dentist
so we just got out of the dentist that
was our first couple's doctor's
appointment
people who smiles together stays
together
you just kissed my smile and i kissed
your big teeth
and the dentist was cute uh she yes you
didn't see her face
though i know yeah maybe she could have
like a you know like a cleft lip or
something
who knows but she did say she's gonna
leave her family for me
anyways this is uh you know gonna be
some patreon content
rachel and eric story so make sure you
subscribe
follow and like youtube members or
patreon
okay thank you thank you
all right so that does that so the audio
people heard
me do the snaps but they didn't get to
see the video so like i said make sure
you go to youtube
eric griffin podcast and check out
uh what we just saw for you people that
saw so that's some fun things that we'll
be doing there so
that's great so what i want to talk
about today
a lot of different things to talk about
i guess you know i'm
the show's going great guys so today
when this episode comes out i'll be
on set working on the show
um they got it's what they call the
network run through so we already did
the studio run through
so we had this big network one through
we're gonna get some notes and you know
they're gonna
say take this out put that in change
that outfit whatever they're gonna say
and then tuesday wednesday
thursday we'll be like recording we'll
be taping the show
and then it'll be all up into the hands
of whoever whoever the person is that
makes the choice to
if the show's gonna go or not so fingers
crossed i love that
like collective energy of people rooting
for me
and i feel like that helped with the
initial audition so let's hope that it
helps with uh this
too so you know and it's an interesting
process with a multicam sitcom you know
because i mean the schedule is great and
i think that the covid protocols has
really
fast-tracked or are streamed i didn't
want to say fast track but
streamlined how things are done because
a lot of times
you know when you go to a set they want
you to be there like stupid early
especially for a single cam you know
single camera will be like okay 6am call
time and then you're there for like four
hours before you even do anything
because they just want to make sure
you're there
but now with the coveted protocols
they're going to be like all right
you come in you do what you do get
dressed get a hair and makeup
and boom go on set i think i think it's
going to streamline how
productions are done right now but i
mean the protocols are like so
intense you know and i totally get it i
totally get it because there's a lot of
money on the line
it's a lot of people's jobs all at once
and you just got to make sure it's safe
because
what happens a couple of people you know
you find out somebody on lighting
gets coveted somebody in a wardrobe it's
like all it takes is like two or three
people to shut down a whole production
and that's a lot
i mean that's just a lot to uh
you know you know for a production like
this to get shut down so
they're being ultra safe you know you
have to fill out this
form every single day online you fill
out this questionnaire and when you get
to the gate
you have to show them this questionnaire
like yes i you know
i whatever the thing that they're
showing then they go okay then you move
forward
then there's like like you have to skip
to a stop sign and they and they take
your temperature
and it's like a machine that takes your
temperature while you're in the car it's
actually really amazing
and then you you know then i go to my
parking spot and you know then you know
it's like there's like a b zone a zone
like you know there's all these zones
that only certain people can be a
certain place they really are making
sure that we are
not just safe but just making sure
they're you know they can
trace if something does happen they know
who was where and what was what so
it's pretty interesting and i'm really
having a i'm i just
i'm having the time on my life because
you know this is like one of those
things you dream about when you first
start doing comedy well in my era when
you first came up it was all about like
oh you want to get on a
you know a network television show
you know and i've been on some good
shows i've been on workaholics i've been
when i'm dying up here i was on blunt
talk
but i've never been on like a network
show
so fingers crossed that it goes and you
know i really feel good about it so
i really like the show too by the way
i'm not just saying it because i'm on it
it's very touching it's very moving it's
very funny so
hopefully this is the that that thing
that you know because this kind of thing
that could just change your life you
know it's pretty amazing
so make sure you guys uh
you know anyways what else is up so
i just you know i man i stream a lot
and when i stream i get i get on air
griffin gaming make sure you check me
out on twitch eric griffin gaming
i just get so many trolls man there's
just so many trolls but it's fine i'm
gonna troll such a like a
catch all for like just [ __ ] you
know just people that have an attitude
for no damn reason you know it's like
what what are you what are you acting
like this for so they come and they like
you know
it's always the same stuff too though
you know a lot of people come and
they'll ask about bobby
where's bobby you know they know that
that's like
it's just gets annoying i don't care it
just gets annoying you know
and then they'll just oh they're coming
they just have something to say about my
gameplay or whatever just like and it's
just
a tone it's like a way people say things
the way like the context of how
something is written
sometimes the you know you just go oh
this guy's being a [ __ ]
you know so then it's like and then they
go onto youtube then you get the youtube
comments but i saw this in one comment
and the only reason why i'm talking
about it is because you hear this a lot
as a comedian and i just want to address
it
you hear this a lot you know for a comic
you sure can't take a joke
like that's a big statement that people
say all the time
because you like you're oh you're a
comic how come you can't take a joke
all right let's address this statement
because this would be like if i was an
executioner or if i was like a
professional torturer i work for a
terrorist organization
and i'm a torturer okay it would be like
saying oh man
for a torturer you sure can't take
torture
i mean i mean the two things aren't
mutually exclusive
just because i'm a comic doesn't mean
i'm not a person
you know and by the way when you
when a comic gets when when you say that
to a comic
a lot of times it's because you said
something that's
not funny so we're not reacting to
like oh we can't take a joke a lot of
times we're reacting to
how ill-constructed and terrible the
joke you're telling is
i mean it's you're just not funny
so this is a better example would be
and we're actually more sensitive to
jokes
in a sense of how it's constructed or
did you have a good punch line was it
you know we're just
as a comic you you look at these when
somebody says something funny
and you go oh man and we analyze oh i
know why that was funny ooh well done or
we have that kind of attitude for it so
when you tell
you say some dumb thing and we're like
ugh what was that man what are you
talking about then you like oh man you
can't take a joke
you as that's the assumption that you
think you said something funny
and most of you most of the people that
say
that statement why can't you take a joke
you're a comic
most of the time somebody saying that is
the least
funniest person you'll ever find like
they're like the least funniest person
in the room
you know and we're just more sensitive
to humor
you know of why something's funny or not
i mean it'd be like a chef
you know it's like you cook some food in
the chef and even if your food is like
even a little bit good a chef still
might be like ooh there's too much salt
in this
uh damn i didn't what did you how how
did you have the fire
like they're just attuned to certain
things and they know why something
didn't work
you know they know they could be like oh
you use too much saffron on this
or it's some kind of like you know but
inside baseball thing
you know what i mean why a chef would
like taste somebody's food and be like
eh
this is missing something there's
something going on with this right
so that's the same thing with a comedian
so when you come at a comedian with some
joke
where you know we're like okay because
like i love a good joke
i love a good you know you say something
to me that's like
even if it's mean if it's well
constructed or funny like for instance i
had a buddy of mine
i won't even say who because i don't
want him to get because he would get
sensitive actually
but he said you know so we were
texting and it looks like california on
april 15th it's going to open up
like venues like comedy clubs and
concerts but at 20
capacity so i said to him we're back
baby
and he said yeah but at 20 cent per
capacity so it's gonna feel like your
road gigs eric like
that's funny it's like
got me you know what i mean and i
laughed
but it's it's but it's still someone
else could be like oh that's mean
but it's like when you do a
well-constructed mean
joke if you're if you if you know what
comedy's about
you're gonna laugh because ah well done
well played
you got me so when you idiots
write dumb [ __ ] in my chat
on my instagram and you think i'm being
sensitive because i can't take a joke
nah [ __ ] you're just not funny
write something funny and you will get a
response from me that's like
you know what got me that's really funny
so that's all i want to say
about that it just came to me i just
really wanted to talk about it because
it was so weird
it's cause you hear that all the time as
a comic you know
so i wanted to talk about this um and by
the way i'm sitting here on the desk
i'm usually you know i'm not in my damn
regular thing because of them i had to
move things i had to take my mic
downstairs for them it's just a whole
thing with i don't even know what
they're doing down there you could i
could probably hear them in my
on the sound but you know it's crazy so
look out for that on rachel's channel
or her friend amanda but we will have
they'll i'm sure they'll have make me
post about it or something so
there's that so um anyways i did want to
talk about um
some some current event that that you
know
really got to me i actually want to look
it up right now
um it's about this voting
you know
you know what the this this voting
laws in uh georgia man this thing you
know
so it's like like so here's some of the
most so you know they changed the law
by the way this is something else too
before i even talk about this
do not be one of these people to think
voting doesn't matter because it does
like that this would all the stuff that
happened in georgia really had a huge
impact and it was
directly because of voting you know the
democrats getting those two seats in
congress or the senate whatever whatever
one it is i'm
not an expert on this kind of stuff but
whatever they won inspired the
republican side to be like yo we gotta
let's make let's fix these laws
in their mind they think they're fixing
it you know and then the other side
thinks that there is voter suppression
listen i'm not gonna speak on either one
of these things
i have my own opinion about what i think
should happen
but they have all these things like it's
like voters will now have less time to
request
absentee ballots okay i don't know how
that
and and people say this affects poor
people the most you know there are
strict new id requirements for absentee
ballots
i think there should be okay so i'm with
you on that one
it's now illegal for election officials
to mail out absentee ballot
applications to all voters i don't i
don't understand that one but
okay drop boxes still exist but barely
i mean all right mobile voting centers
are essentially banned think an rv where
you can vote
all right early voting is expanded in a
lot of small counties but probably not
more populous ones all right offering
food or water to voters waiting in line
is now risk a misdemeanor charges
i don't understand that one but okay
um if you go to the wrong polling place
it will be harder to vote
if election problems arise a common
occurrence is now more difficult to
extend voting hours like i don't even
understand some of these
um look let me just get to what i want
to say about this
i don't understand why we're in this day
and age why we are still voting the way
we're voting
why are we voting in person by hand like
this
i think the majority of people should be
voting online
i just think that we're just not there
yet
in terms of how people feel about online
stuff
cyber security it's like a whole big
thing that people talk about all the
time
cyber security you know it's like the
russians are hacking us and all this
stuff
apparently it's still happening anyway
right but look
if we're going to invest any money in
warfare
there has to be some that has to go
towards not missiles
but cyber security so i'm going on the
premise
that we're gonna get our cyber security
in gear but we should be voting
online we should be voting
electronically
basically is what i'm saying and for the
people to think that
it's not safe if you think
the the more human beings you have
involved in the process
to me the more there is chance for error
and mess-up you know i mean just think
about it
i'm putting my voting thing in a box
that's sitting outside
like it's just outside i i did i voted
this year it was in
outside the library in culver city it's
just a box just sitting there there was
raccoons and [ __ ] walking by
like there's no security in this box
it's just a box now who's picking that
up
somebody's got to come pick that up they
put that in the back of a truck and then
what what's going on in that truck
then that truck goes to where is it is
there some vault that they're keeping
these things in
like is there some secure room when do
they count how long is it sitting there
before they do the count how long is it
sitting there before they do the tally
or they put it in like they record it or
that you know
this is all so many human beings
involved in making sure this thing is uh
you know done right
i mean if you think that's safer than
just
hey let's work on the cyber security and
get this done we're already doing it in
in areas of
of society i have clear if you travel a
lot i co
i travel a lot so i have this thing
clear so when you go clear you go to the
airport
they have your fingerprint and then they
actually take your eye
they scan your eye okay they have
the technology all right so now when i
go on a plane
any place that has clear i don't even
have to take out my
id they scan my eye or they take my
fingerprint
they go they see it in the system boom
now he can get on the plane i can get on
the plane
i mean for something as important as
security for an airplane they are using
electronics
all right they're using online services
because
that's an online thing it's on a server
someplace it's secure
we already have face recognition
on our phones like your iphone
is face recognition the iphone is one of
the most
secure devices that we have out there
they've tried to hack iphones many times
now when you hear about people that have
been hacked and that stuff that happened
especially with picture leaks
it's my understanding that it's always
some third-party software that somebody
put on their phone
that that opened a back door for
somebody to come in yes there's malware
and hackware and there's all these kinds
of things
to you know
but that's human error right there it's
not necessarily that somebody's you know
like the movies where somebody's hacking
somebody's phone
it's actually pretty hard to hack an
iphone iphone is actually pretty secure
my point is we have facial recognition
already on the phone
right there you know we should be
registering that way
eyeballs you know they already have your
fingerprints at the dmv
that you you know for you people that
are like well i don't want them knowing
so much about me all this crap all this
[ __ ] you know did you think in your
head all you conspiracy
theory dummies all i'm saying is
this stuff is already going on because
if you have a driver's license they have
your fingerprint they already have your
thumbprint okay
they already have records like that if
you have a phone if you're using your
iphone and you have the facial
recognition
it's already there it's in the apple
server okay it's already there
why are we using that stuff it would
change
all of this voting nonsense you would
have a certain number of days that you
have to vote it's like a voting
opens you have some sort of secure app
that you would have to download
some you know you know you know what i
mean you would get it then you could be
on your computer or your phone you could
you know put all the things in that you
need i want this person that person
you could you could they could have
videos and commercials and things linked
to things so you can like look up
information as you're doing it right
there you have a certain number of days
you send in your vote it goes to our
some secure
server and it's tallied okay it just
would make
voting so much easier
and we would also have a wider net of
people that we could get to vote
i mean listen i know this probably the
comments are probably going to be off on
fire talking about whatever it is
whatever we need to do to move forward
to get to this love point where we are
voting online
like we bank online we pay taxes online
i have jokes about this how come we
could pay taxes online but we can't vote
online
and then somebody's like well it's not
secure well is the money secure
is the money secure because i bet you
that money is secure as hell
i bet you the government making sure
they get their money so let's put the
voting on the same system as the money
collection
because that seems to be working great
100 percent of the time
they getting their money so why can't
they get their votes the same way
so i know whatever your feelings about
it and i'm sure that the comments are
going to be on fire talking about
why we can't and what all i'm saying is
we should be moving towards this
we should be moving towards i thought i
heard obama talking about this too
saying like look we got to get
we got to move forward and you know to
start voting online
i think it's important because it would
legitimately
change the whole political process
because if you can actually get more
people to vote in the safety of their
home they're just in their home
and they're able to just vote we would
get more votes you would you would
actually have a better
tally of you know who who's doing what
uh better polls you know like like these
anytime i hear about a poll
you know this gallup poll who's taking
polls who the hell's poland
who who's ever taken a poll here because
i have never signed up for a poll
and then these polls are always speaking
for me you know
it'll be like you know uh certain aged
men of us you know
and you go like i don't remember taking
a poll like that like
who are the people doing these damn
polls so if you have like a real
actual have it on your phone all right
let's all poll you know they could be
like okay
monday's poll day uh you know like like
you know when they go like uh
when they say like you know how's the
president doing his like whatever that
number is they always check you know his
uh you know his favorability or whatever
they call it i'm missing the words
escaping me right now
but it's like we they should say okay so
monday we're going to say hey who
how do you think the president is doing
from from one to ten and then everybody
would do it on that day all right boom i
think you could have like a more
accurate number
i mean there's so many ways that
technology could streamline a lot of
this nonsense
because it's so politicized right now
like i said i'm not going to speak on if
the republican party as a whole is
somehow trying to engage in voter
suppression
that's not what i'm talking about and at
the same time i'm not talking about the
other side being like
you know you know with these like
accusations
as if there isn't some valid things that
has been changed in the voting i don't
know okay
when i see all this and i hear all the
back and forth and you know major league
baseball is pulling out of georgia
because of this
voting when i hear all this i go man
there has to be a better way to
get this done and i think that
just we're headed towards the most
logical solution to this
is to vote on line
all right that's how i feel about it so
you tell me what you think about it
in the comments should we be voting
online has it been too politicized
because i really feel that it has
you know and it's driving people is
actually driving people crazy
you know it's i just think that you know
like charles barkley had that great
thing he said about
uh he feels like politicians on the left
and a right are trying to keep us
divided so they can control us and
i mean i think there's some truth to
that i mean even i now i sound like an
idiot uh conspiracy theorist type person
but
you know there is something to like you
know the rich getting richer and the
poor staying poor and the middle class
being fractured and
and it's just like you know even with
when you look at
covet and the coronavirus the corona you
know
how political has it been like i
never feel that anybody cares about
health
it's just it's just rare you always when
it's anybody talks about it you go well
what lens are they looking at this
through
and it always has to be that if i feel
like it's like
everything's so polarizing you can't
just have a common sense conversation
and that's all i'm trying to do when i
say
about this it's just like look i'm not
going to get into the politics of the
left to right but i think
both sides would benefit from if we had
a better system of voting
and i say let's vote online
all right
i guess that's all they have to say
about that what's up guys want to talk
to you right now about my
sponsor i love these guys better help
that's better help h-e-l-p
because you know we have so many things
right now that uh interfere
with our happiness the coronavirus all
the restrictions uh you know
how's your job are you back at work or
you know you know just so many things
this year has just
really gotten to us man and
as i say all the time you know therapy
helps
i've been to therapy it really helped me
organize my thoughts and that's what
it's about you're organizing your
thoughts with a professional who's gonna
help you
connect the dots not solve your problems
but help you connect the dots
and this is a safe private online
environment so it's super convenient
right and you can get started in under
48 hours it's it's not a crisis line
it is a self-help line um
like i say it helped me you know because
i i have i had a ton of issues
just as a comment with tony issues and
dealing with my mom
and so you know talking with my
therapist
really helped me like dig deep and to
find out like oh man
this is why i feel that way it's because
of this and once you have that
knowledge it really helps you
when things start to come at you because
you recognize the patterns
but look you you'll get timely and
thoughtful responses plus you you can
schedule weekly video phone sessions
all without having to sit in an
uncomfortable waiting room because i
can't stand that when you're in that
uncomfortable waiting room so
the service is available for clients
worldwide and they deal with a number of
things depression stress anxiety
relationships sleeping trauma
anger lgbt issues self-esteem all that
stuff
and everything you share is completely
confidential it's convenient it's
professional
and most importantly everybody it's
affordable
all right so i want you to start living
a happier life today and as a listener
you'll get 10 percent off your first
month by visiting our sponsor at
betterhelp.com
griffin hear what i said 10 off your
first month
betterhelp.com griffin
join over one million people who have
taken charge of their mental health
that's better help help dot com
slash griffin for 10 off your
first month thank you
and let's get back to the show
all right y'all um
[Music]
so i want to talk about king kong
godzilla
king kong versus godzilla i don't know
if you saw it
but you sh i'm telling you you should
see it it's just monster porn
and i love it not porn in a way like you
know not nasty
it's not like godzilla was like ben king
kong over no
this movie is so campy and fun and it's
just
straight up it just reminds me of the
old school days like when i was a kid
i'm saturday morning cartoon kid like
those days are done
like nobody even talks about that
anymore nobody's like hey you watch
cartoons on set that's such a my
generation thing
jen whatever i am we watch saturday
morning cartoons and i used to love it
so we would watch and i remember those
couches from my era it was like robotech
thundercats he-man um
what else voltron like those were the
cartoons and of course like the tiny
toons and you know
bugs bunny and all those things and and
then we'd watch those on saturday and
then it was like
wrestling and oh i used to wwf that was
great hulk hogan
randy mantra man savage all that stuff
we'd watch wrestling and then
we'd watch kung fu too like black belt
theater i used to love those movies man
all the terribly dubbed kung fu movies
from wherever they were from china
korea wherever they were from all
different places i used to love
those movies man and then they would
show
occasionally these like really terrible
like monster movies man like godzilla
is gaza got a problem with japan okay
because he is just
continuously tearing this city up right
and it's just like the graphics are
terrible but it was just something about
like godzilla just stomping through the
city and just
wrecking everybody and then then you
would like root so then you you didn't
like him because he was tearing up the
city and messing with human beings but
then you'd be like oh we need you guys
look because here comes rodan the big
you know
and here comes king kong here comes like
mothra and all these like whatever the
ma
i don't even i know i'm i know i'm not
doing all the monster names justice but
it just was like i mean i just so i
really had a flashback to my childhood
when i was watching this king kong
godzilla
i just oh man it was so good and the
thing is
it's so it's like a pseudo sequel to
these
like even shittier movies that have come
out in the past five years
and i didn't realize that they were all
connected you know
so i guess they had the king kong
um i think that one of the king kongs
is i think i think that they combined
like cause like the people from the
godzilla and the people from the king
kong are in this movie i think
i don't even know but i did recognize a
couple of people
from the other movies because you kind
of just casually have those movies on in
the background
but they finally did it together so this
was like they're
this is like their avengers you know
what i mean so they had their shitty
movies and then they put it all together
in this
big big fantastic movie yeah it's it's
cheesy
it's corny you know i couldn't tell you
what the story was about
i didn't i didn't get it all i know is
there was a little girl
who king kong liked which i found
ridiculous
by the way like what's this little girl
doing with this big ass monkey
you know what what you doing you know
where's our parents
where's your guardian you don't see out
in the middle of the jungle with this
big-ass building-sized monkey big old
gorilla and
she's all hey hey king kong you know
touching my finger
and i'm like are you kidding me and
everybody's okay with this
i don't know it just it just
child services at some point got to step
in
you know with just with this situation
so you know
they got him in like truman's show
spoiler alert oh well
but you know but you saw in the trailer
they showed in the trailer that king
kong is in this habitat and it just was
just some big old habitat and you know
he throws
a tree after he knows something's up you
know so
and then like godzilla come like so
apparently godzilla has saved everybody
in the last godzilla movie i remember
that because i saw that one
so i don't know what the plot was but
apparently all the monsters rose up
and godzilla was like the king of all
the monsters and godzilla had to like
you know
defeat all them and just once again
destroy everything you know the property
damage once again is just outrageous
and so guys are the goals you know so we
just living with godzilla
like that's the thing i thought was like
so bizarre
about that universe is that godzilla
just comes out of the ocean
and then on a whim can just ransack
someplace
and then he just goes back into the
ocean and we just kind of like well
godzilla's gone let's get back to normal
let's rebuild
you know so it's just that's bizarre but
so godzilla it just the godzilla comes
back because this company is doing
something funky
all right so of course there's an evil
company you know they're doing some evil
company [ __ ]
and then godzilla comes and he's like
for some reason and there's some power
source and it's like look i ain't doing
the story justice because i want you to
watch it
and then of course you know godzilla and
king kong
are like enemies but then the man the
company makes something terrible that
then godzilla and king kong got to team
up so it's like
it's just utter nonsense
[Laughter]
that's i mean that's really the best way
i could just describe it like
just complete utter nonsense
but you know it
it is what it is man but i like i say i
give it thumbs up for
not for story i just just the action
uh just like it was just like i wanted
to go to the movie theater
because i haven't been to the movies yet
i really want to go to the movie theater
but i'm going to wait until the show
finishes taping
because i'm just i have not even gone
out
i went out once and i just been like i
go to the set
i come back because i ain't trying to
like
oh my god excuse me damn
i should cut that out now i'm going to
keep it in i'm just tired guys because i
got to get up
so early and i was helping my girl but
um i haven't gone out i just didn't want
to get sick
i just even though i have my first
vaccine
shot is already done and i get my second
shot on the 11th
so you know and i've taken like five
kobe tests already
every single one negative um but
it is what it is i um you know
you have to do it for the show but i'm
just like i was like ooh i hate to like
go someplace and somebody sneeze by
accident and then like i get
kicked off the show because or because
they don't want to postpone it and they
could
skip somebody else so just that whole
thing will be a nightmare so i'm trying
to do my part so
i haven't really gone out but i do want
to go to the movie theaters
and i'm not sure what the capacity at
the movie theater is if it's 10 20
and i don't even know what that would be
like i wonder if they have the move the
the
if they have the seats sectioned off or
they took seats out i haven't been to
the theater so
tell me in the comments if you have been
to the movie theater
what's that like because i'd like to
know what's going on there because i
just i miss that
i mean it's just so strange like to
think of other things that i haven't
been able to do
i've gone to a couple restaurants and i
like sitting inside sometimes i don't
want to sit outside
uh i just i just don't want to sit
outside and there's some places where
it's nice and it's beautiful but other
times i'm like okay can we see this
light cause i'm just gonna go sit inside
you know i
i feel safe it's not like there's people
all kinds of people walking around
it's actually i think it's safer inside
than outside just optics wise
looks i mean i don't know the science of
that i'm just saying it just feels safer
because
when you're inside they're going
overboard nobody's over there it's just
the waiter the waiter's covered in a
hazmat suit and then but when you're
outside
i see people just walking by tables you
know it just it seems willy-nilly
outside you know i think that the
people are outside so they think they
think well we're outside so it's so
super safe so
i don't know um but anyways
you know i really uh oh i think next
week
i'm gonna find a theater that's open and
i'm gonna go see this movie
in the theater because like i say i
thought i thought it was uh really good
all right another you know a show that i
started to watch
is uh this jenny jenny and george
georgia georgia ginny with my good buddy
brianne brianna howie she's the
star she's been on my podcast um
it's so good like i gotta tell you it's
just a well done show
it's a really well done show and i
highly recommend watching it it's just a
great
sort of like two stories going on at
once which i really like
a sort of coming-of-age story of the
girl ginny
uh and then like this like really
just incredible story of the mom
who had all the things she had to deal
with in her childhood and how
she's trying to raise her kid but also
like keep her kids safe and like
hide her secrets and it's just a great
story and everybody's doing a really
great
job on this show so you know i don't
know what you're into
but i do recommend um jenny
and georgia or georgia and jenny i don't
even know the name but it's on netflix
it's on netflix so i do recommend that
and i'd love to hear some
recommendations from you people too
because i want to do some more
reviews weekly of certain shows so i'd
love a good recommendation
um and you know because i watch on all
kinds of so i have disney
amazon i watch everywhere and i notice
because of what i watch when i look on
netflix i'm getting a lot of the
foreign shows showing up on my thing now
on my q or my because you watch this you
watch that so
and i really like what netflix is doing
with with those shows because a lot of
these shows from like spain
and wherever they're where wherever they
are korea all these different shows that
they have on
you don't really realize that they're
dubbed because they're
actually spending good money on the
actors now like
the the dubbing is so much better than
like those kung fu movies i was telling
you about earlier so
i do like that so like there's certain
shows that you watch and you go oh man
that's pretty good
uh i wonder what that's you know
you know it's like i wonder what that's
um
what you know because you could change
it like sometimes
i've tried on a few of these shows i've
changed the language to like where you
have to lead the subtitles
and i've just gotten so used to whoever
the voice actor is
that i'm like i want to listen to i i
need to have it in english
because it's a different experience i
hate reading movies but also you start
to get used to like a cadence it's like
when you're listening to an audiobook
and i love audiobooks
i love like listening to a series right
but i hate when they change the reader
mid series because in my mind the first
reader
they have the voices that they want to
do there's an inflections and you get
you hear the pattern and you know
when that person is changing their voice
to be like a guy or a girl if it's like
like if it's a girl reading i love
there's this one her name is tavia
gilbert
she's a voice over actor who does like a
lot of audio books
chick is amazing i tweet at her all the
time like you are amazing
but she yo she does a male voice she
does she does all the voices and so i
hate when they
that person is doing their thing and
then they change mid
you know mid series and then you're like
who is this this isn't the person you
know so
i hate when they do that but this is the
same thing when you're like
when you start watching the series then
you switch over to the the the the
native language that they're speaking in
it's just ugh it just comes out weird so
i don't know i don't know guys um
what else i saw that i can't wait to
watch american idol
uh you know i talked about american idol
last week so i will keep you posted on
american idol when that's coming forth
and i really hope this show goes because
it's on abc american islands on abc
so maybe i'll have like an inside track
i want to go to i want to go to the
finale if they're letting people come in
you know i'm just excited i just i love
american idol it's great
uh so this especially this season it's
like a such a tremendous amount of
talent
so make sure you check that out and then
lastly um
the seas the episode three of
falcon and the winter soldier whoo that
show
is great i really like it sebastian stan
alex mackey is i believe his name
anthony mackie anthony it's not alex
it's anthony
um whichever one of those you know the
the
falcon this show is so good i i love
what they're doing i love the money they
spent on it but episode three
was good because they went
they went to go see the guy
from um what which was
which one was it from which one was it
where whichever one it was where captain
america
and iron man were fighting each other
civil war civil war
yeah yeah captain america civil war so
the bad guy in that
the guy from sokovia the fake nation who
who
mastermind them fighting each other and
he was against hydra from the beginning
they bring him back you know and i love
this i love that they're taking all
these sort of like
bc characters you know
from the movie and they're bringing them
into this show and good for those people
because what else they got to do they're
like oh [ __ ] i get to keep this going
this is great
so they keep they bring in all these
people like they brought the girl from
captain america's
you know love interest and they you know
they kept going with her story because
of course
remember she like stole captain
america's gear and the falcons gear and
gave it to them
yeah but so she got in trouble for that
and i love that that little nuanced
thing is so great
so she got in trouble so she on the run
she out of some like foreign country
doing some [ __ ] on her own
and so i love that they added that
little thing
so like all that stuff is still going on
so that you know they went to go see him
to find out
about you know the super soldier serum
you know that's been you know and so
it's just it's just coming to a head i
just i love it it's only episode three
so i do uh highly recommend you guys
watch that but anyways this is a shorty
but goodie
uh once again i do want to thank uh
better help
you know um they were great you know
great sponsor i want to thank them and i
want to thank you guys for
listening and watching we're from with
griffin and uh shout out to
shout out to wiggy that's not his real
name his name's nate
but he for helping me out i mean so you
saw the video
so i'm gonna do some more videos and
that's gonna be i'm gonna start doing
more patreon content so
make sure you check out my patreon erica
patreon.com
eric griffin uh check that out and i'll
have that video is up there i have it
free right now
and so you know i'm gonna start giving
you some content uh
like that iphone in with griffin
straight to a patreon
and you know keep listening and keep
watching and i'll keep you posted i love
giving you guys updates about what's
going on in my life
what's going on with this show and if it
goes or not i'll i'll just keep trucking
along and we'll see
what we'll see what happens next you
know we'll see what happens next
in my life but this is like one of those
things that's like oh man please go
because it would be so life-changing
it's like
it's how the business works man i've
said this before and i'll say it again
it's like
you're sitting at home and you get an
audition and you're like what
audition and then you like you do the
audition and you get great feedback and
then you're like oh my god i'm talking
to the producers and the producers are
like all right come do a test
then you get a test and then the
network's like yeah we approve him then
you're on a show then you're like oh my
god i'm on a show
then you have to film the pilot you have
to wait and see if it gets picked up and
then if it gets picked up you're like
wow
all from one email right one email can
change your life i mean it's like great
pay it's like an easy schedule and it's
like at this stage in my life i'm like
wow
to get something like that would just be
amazing so
fingers crossed people fingers crossed
and keep those good vibes out there for
me so
thanks again for listening and watching
with my griffin uh eric griffin gaming
on twitch every single
well most days because i don't know what
my schedule but most days
you know this coming week i might not
stream a lot but after that until we
find out if the show gets picked up i'll
still be streaming every single day
so make sure you guys check that out i
want you to be safe out there
um you know wear your masks and get your
vaccine that's
my feeling about it because i'm getting
mine i'll let you know how that's going
to i might even
i might even have that be iphone in with
griffin content where i go to
get my uh vaccine shot because um it's
my second one and i'm nervous because
people have gotten like
people have had like they said uh
something they felt something after
they got sick or they had a fever for a
day so i'm nervous about like am i gonna
have a reaction so i'm a little
apprehensive about that and
and i got some shows coming up if you're
in the palm springs area
ian edwards are now going to be doing a
show in palm springs
so i have that stuff on my website which
i have not updated yet
but i still got people hitting me up
about doing my website
so we got that look out for that kind of
stuff too and then you know we'll see
um we'll see how my new uh intern guy if
it works out
the video you know what he's been doing
he made some other videos too like you
got some like greatest
hit stuff so i'm gonna have that stuff
up on facebook
and maybe even instagram because they're
monetizing on instagram now so
you know i don't know i'm gonna be
everywhere so anyways i appreciate you
thanks for listening thanks for watching
and i will see you next week